[Applauso]
care amiche e cari amici arriva da
ferrandina in provincia di matera
la storia che sto per raccontarvi è la
storia del vibrio motocarro una piccola
biblioteca viaggiante a forma di casetta
con tanto di tegole rosse e comignolo
fumante che suscita subito
immediatamente piacevolezza e simpatia
appena incontrano lungo le strade
ognuno sorride il sorriso è il biglietto
da visita ma oltre alla piacevolezza
suscita anche accoglienza e direi
accessibilità il biblio motocarro con il
progetto fino ai margini oltre il
confine
svolge attività di promozione del libro
della lettura e della scrittura
nei paesi piccoli e piccolissimi della
basilicata porta cioè i libri dove ce
n'è più bisogno senza negare a ciascun
bambino il diritto di avere tra le mani
il libro che desidera e lo fa con
straordinaria semplicità i libri hanno
messo le ruote
così si chiama il servizio di biblioteca
viaggiante con prestito gratuito dei
libri che ha una particolarità non ha il
registro dei prestiti il biblio
motocarro semina fiducia con la
consapevolezza però che dietro questa
semina di fiducia
giorno dopo giorno chilometro dopo
chilometro
avete sentito vent'anni 200.000 km
produce un raccolto di responsabilità il
b2 motocarro ha avuto negli anni ma quel
1999 ha avuto negli anni la capacità di
sapersi innovare rimanendo se stesso il
mezzo è sempre quello mezzo umile
semplice povero lento però alla prima
attività i libri hanno messo le ruote
aggiunse i libri bianchi prima che io vi
dica che cosa sono i libri bianchi mi
piace raccontarvi una storia
ero a san mauro forte un comune della
collina materana e stavamo facendo
l'attività i libri hanno messo le ruote
fanciulli di della scuola secondaria di
primo grado stavano scegliendo il libro
che avrebbero ottenuto per un mese il
biblio motocarro di solito torna
scadenza di un mese
a un certo punto una fanciullina bulgara
ad alina timidamente da dietro con un
filo di voce mi disse maestro e 6 libri
l'iscriversi boloni una espressione di
una tale forza maestro esselibri
scrivessimo noi era una richiesta di
raccontarsi di raccontare la sua storia
quando la mamma
comunico che avrebbero lasciato il loro
paese che sarebbero venuti in italia
basilicata in provincia di matera a san
mauro forte che bella cosa da linee ci
pensiamo in realtà io non ci pensai ha
fatto andare a matera acquista i 200
volumetti di 80 pagine bianche con la
copertina rossa verde e azzurra che
potesse dare l'idea del libro
e lì diffusi per tutti i paesi della
basilicata per offrire la possibilità di
raccontare di raccontarsi che cosa sono
i libri bianchi sono libri composti da
racconti scritti da bambini di paesi
diversi una storia comincia in un posto
poi quella storia continua in un altro e
poi in un'altra ancora storie che si
intrecciano un laboratorio itinerante di
scrittura ma soprattutto una
straordinaria opportunità per il mondo
della fanciullezza di raccontare e di
raccontarsi e ce n'è tanto bisogno
e poi il cinema letterario entrare con
la testa uscire con gli occhi
ieri sono stato al rione isola e poi
alla biblioteca la chiesa rossa e quando
i bambini di questi quartieri periferici
sono entrati nella casetta che è in
realtà un cinema itinerante e hanno
visto i cortometraggi di animazione
fatti da bambini su testi letterari
io leggevo la polizia la filastrocca poi
dicevo bambini andiamo al cinema al
cinema
io arrivo gli sportelloni posteriori
entravano e si accendeva questo cinema
dalla pagina al mondo un altro
laboratorio si parte da una pagina di
letteratura e i fanciulli scrivono altre
storie
queste storie poi si intrecciano
diventano una storia unica una
sceneggiatura i fanciulli diventano
interpreti di una storia che loro stessi
hanno scritto partendo da una bella
pagina di letteratura il biblio
motocarro nacque a scuola
42 anni di maestra elementare io facendo
il maestro parlo di 25 anni fa con leva
ogni giorno questa crescente
disaffezione nei confronti del libro
questo progressivo affievolimento del
rapporto tra libri e mondo della
fanciullezza bambini
c'è un problema bisogna fare qualcosa
maestro fallo tu questo qualcosa e
dicendo questo gettavano un seme dentro
di me e che cosa trovava questo seme
trovava una candela
cari amici i miei genitori erano
contadini e quando mia madre spegneva la
lampadina di casa la lampadina di casa a
casa mia c'era una sola lampadina
io che allora otto anni 9 anni quindi
parlo di 65 anni fa mi stavo
appassionando al piacere di leggere alla
gioia di leggere per poterlo fare
accendevo una candela quella candela non
si è mai spenta dentro di me è ancora
accesa e alimenta la passione che mi
porta a percorrere 200 mila chilometri
maestro perché lo faccio perché mi piace
se la risposta che spesso questo aspetto
spesso do ad increduli che sentono sono
partito alle 4 di mattina la usi
chiedono ma come perché lo fai
torniamo a scuola perché la scuola cari
fan
care amiche e cari amici a scuola nella
vecchia cara scuola elementare
accadevano delle cose straordinarie che
cosa è accaduto a me che i bambini che
nel frattempo erano diventati fanciulli
eravamo passati dalla seconda alla terza
alla quarta quando hanno sentito dire e
maestro qui c'è un problema
i libri si stanno allontanando non mi
hanno detto più puoi farlo tu questa
cosa no maestro la devi fare tu questa
cosa cogliendo un elemento fondamentale
perché sarebbe stata
bella questa cosa se l'avesse fatto un
architetto un ingegnere un commerciante
un operaio no ma se a farla fosse stato
un maestro sarebbe stata bellissima
hanno avuto ragione hanno avuto ragione
loro
come sempre loro i bambini quindi dovevo
fare qualcosa
la devi fare tu questa cosa si trattava
di capire cosa
e allora bastava richiamare l'attenzione
su quel problema che stava emergendo
bastava lanciare un grido d'allarme ma
che stiamo facendo ma possiamo fare a
meno dei libri no non bastava
l'iniziativa doveva avere dentro di sé
una possibile soluzione è la soluzione
non poteva che essere quella mettere le
ruote ai libri scomodarli e le ruote
dovevano essere tre quelli di un mezzo
più umile più semplice più povero
ribadisco più lento
un'idea rivoluzionaria da sempre i libri
sono stati in auto simbolo ed
espressione di una cultura aristocratica
elitaria per pochi a di pochi
bisognava allargare bisogna allargare la
base democratica
bisogna andare alla ricerca di nuovi
lettori con un mezzo accessibile il
motocarro dalle nostre parti è il mezzo
che porta la frutta la verdura
all'angolo della strada sotto casa e
bambini corrono
ecco la stessa cosa succede con il
biblio motocarro e sanno che trovano i
libri non trovano pop corn gelati
eppure corrono ecco accessibile un mezzo
che potesse e che possa consentire
questo allargamento della base ed
europea è stato facile no
ho trovato ostacoli
vi racconto una storia che vi sembrerà
una favola ai contorni della favola ma è
una storia vera
i primi anni il biblio motocarro non
riusciva a superare 30 35 chilometri
orari
dico sulle grandi strade che costeggiano
i fiumi la basentana la val d'agri la
finnica la bradanica non sapevo spiegare
perché certo il libro motocarro e
pesante 10 quintali
ma c'era qualcos'altro e lo scoprite
c'era qualcos'altro
era il disappunto la contrarietà dei
libri che non avevano gradito quello che
io avevo fatto di averli scomodati ma ci
si crede di essere ma cosa pensa di fare
questo maestro
noi eravamo collocati su scaffali alti e
nobili diceva un libro all'altro libro
questo ci ha messo su scaffali modesti
di un modesto e umile motocarro e ci
porta in giro per le strade e noi siamo
i libri e quando io sai questo li si e
fatta la partita è vinta perché sapevo
che avrebbero cambiato idea
altrimenti non sarebbero stati i
capolavori della letteratura per ragazzi
infatti dopo qualche tempo comincia a
sentire capitani coraggiosi che diceva
che poi il maestro non ha avuto una
cattiva idea
sì è vero aggiunge va a peter pan
stavamo su scaffali alti e nobili ma ero
anche ai ricoperti di polvere lui si
porta da un paese all'altro per queste
strade stupende della basilicata e
soprattutto passiamo dalle mani di un
bambino a quelli di un altro bambino che
la ragione per la quale siamo stati
scritti per cui oggi cari amici il primo
tokar banche a 50 a volte supera il 50
chilometri orari
perché io sono spinto dall'entusiasmo
dei libri che hanno capito che insieme
dobbiamo andare alla ricerca di nuovi
lettori vi sembrerà una favola ma è una
storia vera
certo mi rendo conto ai contorni della
favola ma è quello che è realmente
accaduto
i primi anni quando apparve il libro
motocarro in tanti finissero maestro
sorpresa ma cosa hai fatto una cosa
vecchia supera ancora paul libri ma se è
rimasto al mondo antico ormai libri sono
superati e io rispondevo guardate il
video show car è un'idea post moderna e
mentre oggi si parla di umanizzare la
tecnologia
io già vent'anni fa dicevo che il b b
motocarro era espressione dell'umanesimo
moderno dove moderno però è aggettivo
cioè qualcosa che si aggiunge al
sostantivo invece che cosa è accaduto
care amiche e cari amici in questi 25
anni cioè moderno osservando i nostri
comportamenti comportamenti di tutti
giovani e meno giovani uomini e donne
cosa facciamo cari amici quando andiamo
in un posto
la prima cosa che facciamo e vediamo se
siamo con
se siamo collegati
se c'e la rete altrimenti andiamo nel
panico più assoluto ci dà una libidine
particolare sapere che possiamo essere
raggiunti da ogni parte del mondo
poi siamo scollegati l'uno e l'altro che
sono a fianco di banco marito e moglie
mamma e figli e allora il moderno
l'aggettivo ha detto io devo fare la ggd
suo che sei nelle mie mani ma io gioco
una partita tutta mia
divento modernità e infatti è diventata
modernità ma una modernità senza
umanesimo quella che a cui stiamo
assistendo
non è nemmeno modernità ma un vuoto
serie fucile banale modernismo e allora
io ho l'orgoglio e l'ambizione di dire
che con questo mezzo umile semplice
avendo messo le ruote ai libri non solo
svolgo questa azione di promozione del
libro e della lettura e farlo credetemi
nei paesi che non arrivano a mille
abitanti dove questo fenomeno continuo
dello spopolamento
in tanti paesi dove non ci sono le
scuole e dove ci sono sono pluriclassi
farlo li sfida non solo un ruolo sociale
un ruolo culturale ma capisci che svolge
una così un ruolo che ha un valore
profondamente etico dicevo oltre a
questa cosa che è già importante
pensate ai libri bianchi questo
laboratorio itinerante di scrittura
ecco il dubbio motocarro all'orgoglio e
l'ambizione di portare avanti il
concetto dell'umanesimo moderno e lo fa
con l'umiltà
di un mezzo che il motocarro e con la
semplicità della proposta grazie
[Applauso]